okay
all right so
[Music]
i say that to prime myself
ladies and germs boys and girls this is
tim ferriss welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show this is a rare
in-person interview i think this is the
first time
doing a full shebang with video
since kovid the appearance of that
little bug you may have heard of it
and let's jump right to the intro my
guest today is live burrie that's
b-o-e-r-e-e
on twitter at live underscore brie she's
one of the uk's most successful poker
players
now a resident of austin texas winning
both european poker tour and world
series of poker championship titles
during her professional career before
poker she studied astrophysics and now
focuses her time as a tv host and
youtuber specializing in game theory
futurism and rationality what a world we
live in that you can now do that on
youtube it's [ __ ] amazing it's
incredible she also gives seminars on
high stakes decision making and recently
spoke at the annual ted conference about
the application of poker thinking to
everyday life in 2014 she co-founded
raising for effective giving
r-e-g parenthetically let's try that
again she coveted raising for effective
giving in parentheses reg
let me try that again in 2014 she
co-founded raising for effective giving
reg a non-profit based upon the
philosophies of effective altruism that
raised more than 12 million dollars for
its carefully selected list
of maximally cost effective charities
you can find her online
livebury.com livebreed.substack.com
and on all of the things all of the
socials twitter instagram youtube you
can certainly search and find her liv
marie
liv
welcome to the show it's nice to see you
thank you for having me
we can go so many different directions
i thought we would start actually maybe
in an unexpected place so i asked you
before we started what color would you
prefer black blue
orange or i think it was yellow and
that's what it was for mike it was from
mic cable so that i can tell which line
is feeding into which input on this
recorder it certainly looks a lot better
in audio right so it does have a certain
clown car appearance to it when we do it
in person with video but
when you said black i said i bet
it's going to be black right beforehand
and it was black and the reason i said
that is i read something about you
and metallica
and
to get into the zone coming here on the
drive over i listened to orion the
remastered oh great choice yeah nice
choice very very uh because my first now
we're really getting off track here but
that's okay there is no track my very
first album i ever bought was on
cassette tape and it was master of
puppets
and
can you guess why i bring up
metallica
well they were
my
love that bordered on an unhealthy
obsession from the ages of like
16 to 22.
so that's probably a i would guess why
that is a big i don't
well you know we do research over here
middle insider.net
the iron maiden of the poker world they
called you and there's a short
discussion of the unforgiven
and
this led you i guess in some respects
into guitar do you still play guitar i
don't you don't but you did for a period
of time i did yeah from like 16 or 17
till
24 basically until poker took over so do
you then have
typically one obsession at a time do you
ever have multiple obsessions
simultaneously or do you tend to have
one
obsessive fixation and that is where you
put your energy i used to
i used to be very
there'd be a shiny new
activity would come along and i would
if it takes enough boxes i'll be like i
have to become the best at this
i would rarely become the best at it but
i would certainly you know go
go down the rabbit hole deep enough to
become proficient and
i was like that i would say until
some point in my
probably my early 30s somewhere at some
point around the age of 30 where i
lost that a little bit and in some ways
that's good because it means i can try
more you know a greater breadth of
things but it comes a little bit at the
cost of men not ever picking
i'm currently struggling with the fact
that i'm i'm being too much of a jack of
all trades master of none like not
knowing what i'm am i going to be
focusing on youtube or maybe i should
just do speeches or maybe i should
actually just start a company and give
up on the silly like
public-facing stuff you know it can be a
bit of a blessing and a curse i guess
of not
not fixating on one particular thing but
certainly as a as a teenager
certainly with metal because i think you
know with teenagers they
so often you you don't because you
haven't formed your identity yet right
you will form it typically around a
genre of music sure i was a metalhead
you were metalhead oh for sure i'll say
right so yeah you get it like a metal is
so
i mean i say was as if it's past tense
if i'm in the gym i'm still a metal head
right exactly but you don't look it you
don't live it in your visual
no i mean i have like from the neck up i
definitely have the sort of
early era well actually no like mid-era
pantera
finance elmo like a little bit you know
phil anselmo after he's you know vulgar
display of power or whatever yeah
yeah so i was kind of uncool until the
age of 16.
and then metal came along and i was like
oh this is this is what i was waiting
for and then i just went all out you
know i had the piercings red hair black
hair blue hair the guitar and just would
not listen to anything but metal and not
just like
sort of new metal i hated new metal no
corn or anything like that no i wanted
some really heavy [ __ ] like pantera was
like a that was like a nice day on the
beach you know i'm talking like
dimu bulgier bursum you know there's
some of the the swedish swedish black
metal or norwegian black metal once you
get to the scandinavian yeah death metal
and you've gone really deep yeah exactly
but metallica were a huge forming part
of that they were the one sort of
classic metal band that i still was like
i just loved so deeply
all right let's let's paint a picture
here what was your the age range of your
competitive poker career and then we're
gonna back into that
by going to some very early early
chapters but what was the span cause i'm
trying to overlay that on what you just
said
so
i first learned to play poker aged 21
yeah it was 2005. i just graduated uni
didn't really know what i wanted to do
thought i was going to carry on in
physics but i decided to take a gap year
because
when i first started taking physics i
was like oh i'm definitely doing this
this is so interesting i love it but
then
the more time i got to spend with like
uh phd students or even people doing
their masters they seemed
i don't know they just didn't seem very
happy and
i don't know just personality-wise i was
wondering if it was actually it was
going to work for me
because all i really wanted to do was go
out partying and clubbing and go you
know see rock shows metal shows and i
was also still wanting to be a rock star
at the time and i was like uh i just
don't know if this is gonna quite work
me sitting in a lab you know fiddling
around with lasers so decided to take a
gap here
and
i think i signed up oh i was doing like
random like goth modeling sometimes and
i as one does
and they're gap year right well i you
know just any way i could make some
money and i thought i don't know i
enjoyed dressing up in my my heavy metal
costumes as often as possible and i was
like if i can get paid to do that that'd
be great i also got paid to be a cage
dancer
in
rock clubs in london yeah well you know
i was admiring the the boots
on the way in this is uh the shoeless
household so thank you for accommodating
this is
these are gray and pink striped socks
with hearts all over them so yes it's
it's well it's like the hard exterior
the goth death metal exterior and then
like the the soft sweet
inside do you understand how much paint
i'm in actually the fact that this is
these i have so many like most of my
socks are black
i just grabbed whatever i needed to do
so goth modeling which i also had during
my gap year totally lying i'm kidding
i'm kidding
and i wish i i wish i could have but
goth modeling cage dancing
and
and then and then yes so
i think i signed up for this like
website that
would advertise different tv shows or
modeling opportunities that kind of
thing and i remember seeing an ad which
said something like could you use your
powers of skill and deception to win 100
000 pounds on tv
and seeing as i was you know rapidly
getting pretty damn broke because
dancing in a rock club cage doesn't pay
you anything really and i had some
student debt mounted up but really
didn't want to get a real job for you
know my parents were like you have to
like what are you doing you've moved to
london get a job
so i was like okay i'm gonna
this seems reasonable i wanted to try
being on tv
i like game shows this seems like a game
show i'll apply
turns out they wouldn't tell us what
what it was that we were applying for
because they needed to keep it a secret
but turns out it was a reality show that
was looking for five beginners
at poker to teach them how to play and
the sort of loose scientific premise was
they were looking for five different
personality types uh to see which you
know is most suited for the game
and so i got selected for that what was
your personality type
they called me the professor
which i most certainly wasn't i could
see it i could see it i it was what i
literally turned up in
skintight tiger print spandex self-made
trousers now did you do that because
they had put you in the professor
category was that a rebellion an act of
rebellion or did that just no i mean
that was genuinely how i dressed it was
style emoting no it was it was my
genuine appearance as i said i lived and
breathed metal sounds good for tv right
and i think that's probably why they
selected me honestly like that was
strange very very overconfident to the
point of like cocky
21 year old
brat
unheard of with 21 year olds yeah i just
thought i was the smartest person in the
world and i think i even said something
like that in the interview like they
auditioned and they're like oh we're
definitely bringing together this is
gonna be a good one and i didn't
disappoint because i ended up having a
complete meltdown on the show like
so glad this is not the internet
basically on the final i think we played
like seven
preliminary rounds where we would the
five of us would play yeah and then like
that would accumulate points and those
points would translate into chips for
the final game where we would play for
the hundred thousand
and i was winning you know i was leading
going into that and clearly i had a
knack for the game
and i remember the the hosts and the
the professionals that they bought on
the show to teach us were like oh you're
definitely going to win you know you are
the most talented at this so i was so
sure i was going to win this thing and
then
i ended up making
not to get too technical but basically i
misread my hand
oh no i didn't i misread the board
i made a straight on the river the
opponent bet i was so excited i was like
i raise which was basically all my chips
and then i looked at the board again and
noticed there were four diamonds out
there
and i didn't have i might i had two
black cards
and audibly went ah
no i'm not i'm i'm no professional but
is that what dante one would call a tell
yes that is that is a tell
do not do that
and
my opponent it was a really nice guy
called lee
it was like well i guess she doesn't
have a diamond
and he's like i'm all in and instead of
again keeping my my cool or anything i
just started crying like melted down the
producers are high-fiving
yeah they were literally and and
and i'm like oh liv what's the matter
tell us more and i was like
makeup everywhere i think i i like run
away from the table they try and follow
me with a camera it was just you know
classic reality tv meltdown stuff
so that was my intro to poker but i just
completely fell in love with the game
and funnily enough while i was in the
during the filming of that which took
two months
i went to a local card club in london to
try and get some practice
and
they had this
now sort of infamous this five pound
rebuy
so you know it was the cheapest
tournament they had what is a rebuy a
rebuy means that for the first hour or
so if you bust out you can just buy back
in again so considering it was only five
pound entry you can imagine it's just
pandemonium everyone's going in every
single hand and people will easily like
spend like 100 pounds in their entry
overall you know 20 rebuys good for the
house yeah but i turned up with 10
pounds because i was like well it's a
five pound tournament why would i ever
need more than you know five pound for
the entry and five pound to buy a drink
and that will be my my day so you're
like a player in a video game with
two lives where everybody else has like
a hundred lives right yeah and most
people were doing that yes
only for the first hour then once that
period ends then if you bust out you're
out yeah so anyway i go and this is the
first tournament i ever play and i enter
this thing
somehow get through this
carnage period in the first hour the
zombies i think i did keep yeah i think
i did buy once with my other five pounds
so i didn't buy a drink
and anyway i ended up winning it
ended up playing until five in the
morning it was like 120 people in it and
i came home i remember just having this
you know they paid me out in tens and
twenties i think 750 pounds or something
like that which was
more money so i'd never seen that amount
of cash before just so much money and i
remember going home to my boyfriend at
the time and waking him up at 5am and
just throwing the cash on him
like this is the best thing ever this is
my game and i must be the best in the
world like you know it's my first ever
tournament basically and i win it so
even though the tv show did not go well
and i didn't win 100 grand
i'd already got the bug basically from
that little win so let me
weave through this and inspect a bit
because i have many questions
what do you think helped you
during
the show itself to make it to the final
table what were some of whether they're
your characteristics
things you learned
things you observed
trained abilities anything that comes to
mind that you think
helped in the very early nascent stages
of that tournament yeah the tv show and
then i have more questions
i mean i think the thing that was most
helpful early on
for me in poker was
i was just so pathologically competitive
i just had to win and like
prove that i was the best and that
translated to just more study time just
yeah just
laser focus and then there's like
ruthlessness because the thing about
poker is that you actually you do have
to be really ruthless in the game in
what sense in terms of being willing to
put people like what bluffing people
right
if you're not comfortable with bluffing
someone at the poker table which i don't
think a lot of people say oh it's lying
it's like it's not really lying no it's
just a form of it's a strategy within a
game as defined by the rules of the game
it's an integral part of it it's
sanctioned lying right if you're not
willing to do that then
it's not the game for you play chess
right
and then you have to be
just willing to
i guess just really
laser in and pay deep attention to what
is going on because technically at any
given moment even if you're not in hand
there's really valuable information
being exchanged about the way people you
know the types of cards people play the
way that their bodies move when they're
uncomfortable versus comfortable are
they a naturally aggressive person are
they naturally scared what are the
things that make them scared etc
and
certainly in the beginning i was just
because i didn't know anything about the
actual statistical sort of the mechanics
of the game
all i could rely on was
the you know the stuff i knew which was
looking looking for when people are
bluffing
looking for when people are bluffing
okay so let me ask you about the
statistical side because you're coming
out of physics
you have it would seem a huge
competitive advantage
why would you not
begin to study the tables and the
statistics and so on well i did too you
did that and the thing is that the
statistics required in poker
to actually you know at a high level are
you're not going to learn within the
first month sure right and also people
didn't even really know because this is
2005. even the top players in the world
back then didn't really understand game
theory
like even an average player understands
it today
so
you know i was reading i read all the
books i could get my hands on so i guess
my sort of physics training helped to an
extent with with being willing to just
like dive in and research on this like
on a big amorphous topic and you know
not even clear directions of where to
start that probably gave me a bit of an
advantage there and then presumably i
have a higher than average iq from you
know
dancing exactly it really helps uh and
all the drinking and guitar playing and
chasing after rock stars yeah um
but
which i think obviously helps in any
kind of strategic game yeah but honestly
the thing about poker is the beautiful
thing about pokemon fact is that in any
given if you're if you're talking about
one night
you can have the literal best player in
the world
a medium player
complete beginners
and provided everyone knows the basic
rules then technically anyone can win
it's only over the long run does
anything actually meaningful start
happening
and so
even in this tv show where we played i
think eight different games
statistically it's not that meaningful
the results over that time period
there's so much luck going on and
i didn't realize that early on in the
game
like winning that big tournament of not
a big tournament that the five pound
rebuy it gave me an immense amount of
confidence and love for the game which i
think had i not had i wouldn't have then
pursued it as much as i did
but it can also delude you a little bit
because i then just assumed okay well
i'm going to win this there isn't that
much luck it's just who's the best
player wins and i think that's partly
why it was such a kick in the face when
i screwed up and didn't win 100 000.
when you say you fell in love with the
game aside from things that maybe you've
mentioned already
what made you fall in love with it what
was so appealing
i mean there's an inherent excitement to
it right of course because there's a
blending of skill and chance yes
and money i mean they're stakes right
we're actually just winning cat the
potential of just winning
you know making a living
where i don't have to go and sit in an
office and i can do that that was
obviously a big
driver
yeah there's just so many different
skills that it draws upon
so there's the statistical side you know
the scientific side
there's the
the game theory if you really want to
dive deep into math and i mean these
days you can you know work with
simulators you know computer science
stuff basically and go in that angle but
then you've also got this more
there's like an art to it as well you
know psychology meant trying to mentally
model what level someone is thinking at
and be one step ahead of you know
they're going to zig you're going to zag
that kind of thing
and then also just like there's a
scientific way to read body language but
sometimes you just get like a vibe that
you can't explain
yeah so there's just so many different
approaches you can take to it and like
today i'm going to work on my body
language reading and today i'm going to
work on my pot odds and my combinatorics
there's never a dull moment and there's
always a new situation as well like even
after playing for 10 15 years i'll still
see something crazy with like the cards
run out like you know straight flush
against quads that kind of stuff like
these
incredibly rare scenarios will sometimes
happen or people will do weird things or
some strange ruling will happen that
like everyone's scratching their heads
like i don't know what the right call is
here it's it's there's such depth and
complexity to the game
okay so
i'm going to admit something it's
embarrassing
i've been fascinated and drawn to poker
for a very long time and i've never
learned how to play properly no way it's
true wow now there are many excuses i
may have for this
one of them is that friends of mine like
a guy named jason calcanis want me to
play but it's mostly because he wants to
take all my money
because he's going to be far better than
i am
and that's a compliment jason
i'll teach you how to beat json and a
lot of these investors
are
very confident i know some of them
certainly
particularly the quants who i've
observed from afar seem to be
pretty competent
i had
a little
a little bite of the bug
probably five years ago when i did an
episode of a tv show
bringing back tv
where i trained for a week or five days
probably to play heads up
against
a whole cohort of folks including some
pros and i was able and i was trained by
i want to give him credit phil gordon
for that
and
for a very short period of time
until the next skill i had to learn for
the next episode pushed it right out of
my head had a lot of fun with heads up
but one night when the filming had
finished
and i was like you know let me go try
just a regular table and i got
slaughtered
like it did not translate at all which i
expected would largely be the case but i
just got
dismembered i mean well that's a
heads-up is a very different game
playing against eight people yeah
totally so yeah one-on-one a totally
totally different game
but it actually brought back in a way my
love of mathematics and statistics which
i lost
not to make this like a confessional but
i lost it in 10th grade because i had
this one teacher who just had this huge
axe to grind with the boys in the class
and almost all the boys ended up
quitting math or avoiding it after that
class my brother had the opposite
experience and then later became a phd
in statistics
so
it's amazing to look at these divergent
kind of points right where you have a
fork in the path depending on your
experience so my question after all that
word salad is
if if you were to
suggest a way of learning
or to teach me
an approach to learning
regular poker whatever that means
the type of poker i would play with my
friends who are like let's play poker
right
how might you think of approaching that
well given that you
are
i mean you're pretty well-rounded in
your personality and that you like both
sort of human interactive things but you
can also nerd out really hard yes i
don't think there's really a wrong way
to teach you poker like if i was to
teach my my mum or something like that
my mom is the most
sounds strange she's the least autistic
person
in that she is
so
able to intuit
social situations
and
unbelievably emotionally intelligent but
could not she's like phobic of math
she's interested in sort of scientific
concepts but if you actually try and get
into the technical weeds she's like she
cannot it's like she would be
in arms with molly right now just like
she's just she just feels she's a very
feel-based person if i was to teach her
the game you know i would
take her to the table with a group of
fun people and you know we would slowly
just like turn the cards over and you
know talk through i'll give her the hand
rankings and we take it very steady in
in terms of like this is look how the
way that they're acting so they seem
quite confident you know take a more
human approach to it
but i think with you we would want to
jump sort of straight into the game
theory to an extent so let me apply some
parameters if i could just to allow
us to conjure
an image so let's just say
he's really going to want to take my
money now which he will probably so
let's say i had a game with jason and
you can pick
the sort of minimally viable period of
time over which you think i could learn
to be competent enough that i might have
a chance
is it
four weeks is it
12 weeks and this is also not knowing
how how good jason is i have no idea
because i've always refused to play but
he's pretty good okay great so let's
just say
you know if luck is on my side having
some
chance in hell well here's the thing so
you have a chance in hell anyway if you
sat down and just played it's not just
going to be jason it's going to be an
entire team well no but even if you were
playing one-on-one against jason if you
guys sat down assuming you know the
basic rules of like which hands there's
always a chance okay but let's you know
assume that the very basics you know
what betting chips means whether you
have a straight on the river or not
assuming that you and i could sit down
and play 10 hands and it's basically 50
50. who wins okay let's say you can pick
the period of time of training right
right
however long it is and then jason and i
are going to play a thousand hands
yeah a thousand hands
you're already
your chance of beating jason over a
thousand hands probably with like just
knowing the rules is
45 percent
that's how crazy like that's the thing
maybe it's a bit less than that maybe
it's sorry jason maybe it's
let's say thirty seven percent maybe
thirty five uh he's going i'm gonna get
a phone call after this um
uh
but you know could we get it so that you
are a favorite against him
eight weeks of intensive okay yeah if
you sat and studied all the charts
because that's what it is really these
days so poker is now that we know the
mechanics of the game basically there's
this thing called game theory optimal
solutions to different scenarios which
is basically you know if you have jack 9
suited on this type of board against a
person in this position you will want to
check raise them
30 of the time and check calls 70 of the
time or something like that basically
there are like answers to what you
should do in different scenarios with
what frequencies
it's all about frequencies and so
now that we know this and and you can
run simulators to give you the answers
of all these fictitious scenarios now
it's changed the game into a basically
who's willing to
you know learn as many different
scenarios as possible and like basically
emulate them in their head when they go
and play
so it's a very different type of game
it's more like kind of almost studying
chess moves i was just going to say it
sounds a lot like studying like chess
scenarios and it wasn't like that even
10 years ago it was very very different
i mean there were some it was more about
you you'd sort of do com combination
calculations in your head and that kind
of thing but that was kind of the limit
of it and honestly it's actually one of
the reasons why i
in the end didn't like the game as much
anymore
i've been doing it for
12 years anyway and i was just starting
to get itchy feet naturally but
it required
more and more
time spent to at the top levels at least
these incremental gains exactly
diminishing returns in terms of hourly
because also what it means is because
it's like these game theory optimal
solutions exist
it means that there's technically this
perfect style of play that anyone any
one person can play
and
the more
the more people study this style the
more people are close to it
and so that means there is a ceiling of
how perfectly you can play like
technically if you and i are both
two computers that are able to play this
game theory optimal style we're just
breaking even against each other over
infinity over the short term you know if
we play for an hour whoever gets the
best cards will therefore win but over
infinity
we will just break even and so that
meant that you would have to be putting
more and more time in to win a a sort of
shrinking pot of money essentially which
is why i don't now recommend to people
to go out and try and be professionals
in poker but i still absolutely
recommend that people go and learn the
game because it is
probably the best way
to it's it's the best
mini analog for the type of complex
decision making that you need to do in
life
that you could do
and we're going to come back to this
because i do think with my very little
exposure to poker
and having watched some on tv
and nonetheless having had my ass handed
to me
when i tried it live
that
particularly maybe an easy map is
investing
and poker because there's there are just
so many variables that are similar
which is why i think so many investors
are drawn to it
and also give a plug all in podcast
check it out that's jkl's podcast with
his buds it is a fantastic fantastic
show i do think it is one of the the
best newish podcasts that i've put into
my rotation so
don't take all my money jason
eight weeks what does the density of
practice look like is that two hours a
day is it
ten hours a week what does the
distribution look like
to be confident that you're that you
will have like a 60 40 edge on him
i would want to do like 40 hours a week
at least okay oh yeah all right 40 hours
how does that break down if we have
you said eight weeks right yeah so
hypothetically let's say week one what
is the schedule and curriculum look like
so in the first week
i think we would
i mean i would sit and
just run out lots of different hands i
think in person is better than online so
you actually just get to play with the
cards feel what it's like you get really
familiar with the betting patterns and
that kind of thing and we would talk
about the more sort of general
things like
you know why are we betting what what
are we seeking to find here okay we want
to find information
we'd get into the idea of like ranges
kind of a strange word but basically you
know if we're playing a hand right now
i don't know anything about your cards
all i know is that you've got two cards
out of the you know a thousand and
whatever the number is combination of
two cards that you can have
so right now your range is a hundred
percent
and same back at you and then as the
hand progresses basically i want to
narrow down the perceived range that i
think you could have you know now gain
information so i can narrow that down
and put you on a hand while meanwhile
giving away as little information about
my own possible range so keeping it as
wide open to you so it's about
maximizing deceptiveness sure while
extracting information out of your
opponent
so i'll teach you about concepts like
that and we would talk about ways that
you can do that and then i think we
would go and actually play a little bit
in person just so you get used to the
again so we don't need to find a table
somewhere yeah i mean probably invite
friends over and we'll just have some
yeah have some games and it's so much
fun anyway those are the best type of
pokemon bring in my card mechanic and
take all their money exactly yes
and then after that i think we would
start i don't know what stage but you
know once you seem competent and and are
able to you're able to do sort of basic
math calculations in your head about
like
okay well i have to call a hundred
dollars into a pot of 400 i'm getting
four to one what does that mean what how
many cards are there that i need to hit
etc so these kind of potholed
calculations that kind of stuff could
you just take a second and explain what
you mean by pod odd calculations so pot
odds are basically
you know like in investing to an extent
if things go well what do you win versus
how much would you lose
and then how do you bet size accordingly
right exactly or like you know let's say
you're you're trying to hit a flush
and there are nine cards left in the
deck that could help you say out of 36.
so you have a 25 chance of hitting the
card you need and meanwhile the pot is
offering you five to one well now it's
actually a profitable thing right you're
getting the pot is offering you more
than the odds that you need to hit your
card so matt and i haven't talked about
this stuff in ages it's really
interesting seeing my brain's like oh
find the words so those kind of
rudimentary types of math calculations
that you need to do
and then as you get more comfortable in
that then you would start doing more
like combination calculations so again
like
as you're sort of narrowing down your
opponent's range
there will be
presumably some hands that they will
have that are better than your hand you
know so what we would call value hands
that they would be playing but they
would also have some bluffs in there so
you need to try and think about what the
conceivable bluffs they would have given
the sort of story that's been told you
know like pre-flop they raised early so
that means they probably have stronger
cards and than uh weaker cards so you
can narrow it down to like the top end
of the cards uh you know
like aces kings ace king
ace three suited that kind of stuff but
then on the flop when an ace came out
they actually slowed down so that maybe
suggests that they don't have an ace
maybe they have more like nines tens
eights you know to a pocket pair like
that you know weaving together bits of
evidence to be able to narrow down
people's ranges and put them on like
conceivable bluffs versus conceivable
strong hands so that kind of stuff after
that
if you know you're seeming to grasp all
that then we would actually start
looking at the the solver charts so
these are these like simulators there's
this one called pio solver that was at
least popular in the day when i was
playing how do you spell that p-i-o
pio solver i think it's still the main
one and
at least when i was you know using it
that was back in 2016 or so it would
take many hours to run a sim
so you know you'd be like i want to know
what the optimal play is with jack 9
suited on a 108 1084
rainbow board or something like that and
then let it run folks listening i have
no idea
i love how the hell about sounds though
yeah there's so much darkness i think i
need a rainbow that's actually probably
where we could start we would start with
glossary because there's so many there's
so many work terms
the vocab is is you know there's just so
much going on there but yeah so we would
start running simulation so you can see
and understand like okay this is this is
what the optimal solutions would be in
these certain situations
because once you know what the optimal
solutions are
then now you can you're sort of equipped
with this like really solid baseline of
what the the perfect play is
where if you don't have any information
about your opponent that you can just
follow
and know that you know at worst you'll
be breaking even but you'll still be
beating them but then because you know
what the perfect play is you can look
for ways to exploit their screw-ups
because in reality everyone even the
pros are making mistakes they aren't
playing this perfect gto style
but you can't really know the way that
they're screwing up until you know what
gto is in the first place so it acts as
this like baseline benchmark of
high quality play so we would sit and we
would study these charts and if over
that course of eight weeks i got used so
that you were able to like emulate these
charts to
you know i don't know how to quantify it
but to a good amount
that would be more than sufficient to be
jason
um because he's you know he's not a
full-time pro yeah he's good like he's
played a lot and we've only played once
and i was more just like bemused at the
amount of words that were coming out
well i was gonna say if his poker is
anything like his basketball his ability
to [ __ ] talk oh is actually incredible
that guy is world-class he's very good
at getting under your skin if he wants
to get on youtube oh yeah
oh yeah we've been at a few parties
together and he has
he knows how to ruffle feathers but he's
so funny
i love him
excellent interviewer and moderator i
just want to second the recommendation
that was made earlier okay
so
let's depart from
the training for
a bit we may come back to it
actually
let me ask a question i haven't asked in
a long time maybe similar this is like
kicking in the gears starting the old
car trying to like turn the key
get it to turn over
if you could
predict
the main reasons
the failure points the reasons i would
quit in those first eight weeks what do
you think they might be
assuming that i had the time right right
and the interest what are the what are
the things that might break me or cause
me to walk
give up
hmm
if for some reason you couldn't wrap
your mind around
what these charts mean
i guess that would be a sort of breaking
point but i just don't see that ever
happening to be honest so it would be
more i think the reason why you'd walk
away
is because you're like ah actually this
isn't that much fun and i'm not playing
for i don't care enough about beating
jason you're not playing for suitable
stakes
and you're like this is not for people
listening i'm just using jesus's
standings it's fun
but right i don't care i don't care
enough about beating anyone exactly just
the opportunity cost would be too high
yeah that would be the only reason i
think because i think you would find it
fun
otherwise and i would have to i wouldn't
have to but
ensure that i have a certain frequency
of play after putting in 40 hours a week
for eight weeks
otherwise the decay rate would well
absolutely be brutal and part of that
time by the way in that 40 year it's not
just studying the charts it's also going
out and actually practicing and getting
real because assuming you're going to
play one-on-one in the in the flesh
um so a big part of poker that we
haven't touched on yet as well is
emotional control understanding yourself
and your own emotional you know your own
biases not only cognitive but also the
way
you know different negative emotions
will will arise which they will in the
game particularly with someone like
jason who is so adept at like saying
things to needle and that's a big part
of the game getting the verbal bamboo
shoots under your finger in there
that would be as important particularly
if you're playing for a particular you
know you're training for a big match
[Music]
the mental game side of it
you know because ultimately you can
study all the charts and think you're a
gto machine
and like oh i'm fine but then you get
down there and he looks you in the eyes
and it's like well you screwed up that
hand tim like what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do huh you know and just
goes for jason on you like you'll forget
everything the red mist
um i call it the white noise
i've never heard that okay the redness
descends like if
so there's there's
two mental blocks that's when one might
go tilt tilt exactly if i'm catching the
light yeah tilt very good
for those who don't know tilt is
what people do basically when their
emotions get the better of them and they
start playing badly
no
is monkey tilt just an exaggerated
version of that yes okay yeah monkey
tells us it's like i love the image what
are the flavors
now the reason that this is fresh on the
mind is not too long ago
i was in a a non-sober state and decided
that it was a perfect time to start
making
stock trades and my friend was watching
he's like
i think you may be full tilt right now
and i was like do i look excited do i
look upset i'm not
i'm not on tilt
those didn't work out very well
but
the red mist when the red mist but you
call it the white what well so there's
two there's the white noise so the white
noise is when
it's less about
so redness is when you're angry someone
has wound you up that would probably be
my
achilles heel right the white noise yeah
and the white noise is where
for whatever reason perhaps you know
you're just really tired or you're
really stressed but you'll go and
consult your brain
and it comes back with nothing okay yeah
you're just beach balling just people
yes
and i've had that a few times like i
remember having it in the world series
day four or something day five and it
was a really big part and i just needed
to think and but then my brain was like
well this is a really important decision
you know you just really pay attention
to this one like are you paying it well
i'm not sure you're paying attention why
are you listening to me and so this
little voice and then i was like okay
pay attention let's count the combos of
what they've got and just
nothing
so in the end i was like
you know my system too are you familiar
with with uh system one system two no
okay uh oh wait a second system one
system two is this like daniel connor
yeah is it done economy if you could
just give some context
his thesis is that we have two modes of
thinking system one is like your
intuitive like if i ask you what's five
plus five you immediately know the
answer is ten just so you kind of you'll
get interesting shot of adrenaline so
that you're gonna make me do
multiplication tables oh wait
wait so that's your system one it's just
the things you immediately know an
answer to or you you know it's like an
unconscious process
you know if you technically it's system
one if you're driving down the street
and someone cuts in front of you
your body will take over and you'll
swerve because you don't have time to do
a sort of cost benefit analysis of going
left or right
and then your system two
is the like conscious thinking
so if i was to ask you what 471 plus 88
is
it would be
i 560 even forget the numbers now nine
471 and 88. 471.88 what's that i got 30
471. yeah nine
five
five five five nine is that right
559
i have no idea five is five hundred and
well i can't even anyway whatever that
was you can't you can't use your gut
feelings for that right you have to
think it through you have to do the
calculation mentally in your head so
that's your system too
poke is really interesting because you
know i'm on five hours of sleep i just
want to buy myself a little bit of
wiggle room on the phone i didn't even
answer my own question yeah and i have
no excuse
may i make a quick aside
one of the coolest things i've ever seen
was when i was 15 as an exchange student
in japan and i
i got to know multiple kids because it's
mandatory
that every kid learned how to use an
abacus
and something like one out of every 30
or 40 kids would get so good
that they no longer needed the physical
abacus they could see it in their minds
and so for party tricks
their friends would just lob these like
three-digit multiplication problems at
them and they could come up with the
answer to take them a second because
they actually had to physically
map it out map it out and move these
beads and so on in their minds but
astonishing my partner igor can kind of
do that yeah it was one of the ways he
got me honestly he just you just throw
numbers at him and he'll
he hasn't done it in a while and he'll
hate that i've mentioned this because
now everyone's going to do it to him but
he can usually answer within like a
second or two wow that's fast yeah it's
hot
rock stars to mental mathematics
you know yeah so those are i don't know
where i was going now so where you were
going is we were talking about system
one system two and that white noise
moment yes and that is not a time that
you can rely on system two is that what
you're going to say right exactly
because system two has shut down system
two is offline yes offline it says not
compute there's nothing there hello four
or four four four four five yes blue
screen of death
and it's bad when that happens yeah
focus
yes
and that is
you know if you're playing you know it
could be various reasons it can be
because you're wound up someone's gotten
under your skin
uh that will shut it off but also just
pure
adrenaline and stress you know you're
excited even i've had it when i had a
really good hand yeah and i was really
awesome oh man i'm gonna win a huge pot
here this is so exciting and i'm like
well i need to think through what the
optimal bet size is and again
yeah because i just uh it just it's so
hard because i think you're you're put
into well you know this stuff better
like
your sympathetic nervous system is in is
in play right uh so you're kind of in
fight or flight and that is not
conducive to slow cognitive thought
it's conducive to immediate you know
physical stuff really useful for but not
so good for the mental so let's talk
about the regulation the self-regulation
so
i'm in front of me some notes obviously
you can see them those who are on audio
only will not be able to see them that's
fine because it makes me sound more
professional if you think i'm doing
everything off the top of my head
so at one point
you turned 500 euros into
1.25 million euros which is around 1.7
million and if i'm getting roughly
i believe that that math right that was
at the ept
san remo
and
it was 500 euro buy-in or 500
it was a 500 euro
satellite tournament into the main event
buy-in which was 5 000 euros so everyone
was buying in for five thousand but i
won my way in because i couldn't afford
the five thousand yeah i i won my way
through a feeder smaller tournament so a
few just housekeeping questions about
this how long after
that first
tournament win after the tv show
was this this was
2010 so five years wow all right
so five years later this happens
presumably in this tournament there was
less
and then crying
and running away from the table correct
okay
so what type of self-regulation
did you learn over that period of time
and then
subsequent to that oh man that that
tournament was nuts because
you know the tv show was in 2005.
i didn't actually
really turn fully professional wherever
i was living off it until
2000
like late 2008
you know i was still sort of playing
casually couldn't really get my act
together enough to to be you know i
wasn't good enough really to be living
off poker before then i'd been playing
on the circuit now for like a year and a
half and i played some bigger buying
tournaments
but i'd never made like any like really
big final tables or anything
and this italy one kind of happened by
accident it was a remember the volcano
that went off in iceland yeah i do and
it shut down all of european airspace i
was in the south of france for something
completely different and i couldn't get
home and someone i heard that there was
this tournament going on in northern
italy and it was like a train ride away
so i was like all right screw it i'll go
there thank god for volcanoes bless that
volcano
oh yeah yeah and then i arrived and
there was this like this feeder
tournament it's called a satellite
that night
where you know it was a 500 euro entry
and one in 10 people would win their
ticket for the 5000 the main event so i
won my ticket that night like four in
the morning
and then went and played it the next day
starting at noon
and
a very strange thing happened to me
actually at noon before the tournament
started but that's like another topic i
think we can get into later maybe wait a
minute you can leave that just give us a
teaser and then maybe we'll come back to
it i had
my first
of
a handful of completely unexplainable
borderline metaphysical experiences okay
all right i won't say what it is it'll
be better if we talk we'll come back to
that later but anyway so i had a very
strange thing happen
just before the tournament started at
noon and
long story short six days later it would
turn it out it ended up being the
largest tournament ever held in europe
undescribed is what i call keeping the
audience yeah yeah you could better keep
watching uh
and now for sure commercial break
i ended up being
attracting the biggest field of players
of any tournament in europe to date at
the time at least was over like 1 200
people so huge huge tournament
and six days later
i was on the final table down to the
final nine how many hours a day are you
playing i played like
10 hours a day on average some days are
a bit longer some days are a bit shorter
so you can imagine how exhausting that
is also because the longer you're going
the more intense it gets because in the
beginning the stakes are like okay i
might you lose my 5 000 euro buy-in but
as the tournament wears on and you know
there's less people your chip stack is
worth more and more in terms of equity
so your loss aversion starts to oh yeah
go go vertical but by the time of the
like you know the end of day five where
we play down to the final table the
final nine
i you know for ninth place
i was already guaranteed i think 90 000
euros
i only had like
i mean i think i had like 50 000 pounds
to my name at this point
so i was already guaranteed double my
net worth for whatever happened on that
final table and first prize was you know
the 1.25 million euros 1.7
and
that morning i did not sleep i mean i i
don't know what i think i got some sleep
the night before
because i i'm somewhat of an insomniac
anyway so if i have something on the
next day that's big i often will just
not sleep very well and so you can
imagine this cranks it up to 10. and i
was dreaming you know i don't if you
ever have that where you've been doing a
lot of a particular thing like trading
or whatever and you sort of a semi-sleep
and see the thing for sure i was playing
poker i was like i was lying there i had
pocket jacks i had a king queen
you know just these fictitious hands my
brain just could not shut off and that
was my night the night before and i was
just like in a complete tears because
i'm like i don't know where to play
tomorrow like i'm a mess
i was so nervous before the final table
i like threw up three times on the way
like walking down
to the thing it was it was so stressful
but like i don't know once we actually
started playing once i got the cards in
my hand it was just like and i just
switched into this like mode
of
i don't know it was weird was that the
first time that it happened or that
happened to you before
not to that extent because i think it
was a perfect storm of like
such extreme nerves and being such a
mess beforehand
and then like actually you know being
able to play well i don't know the delta
felt more than i'd ever had it before
but i had had that before where i was
like able to like get into the zone very
well i wonder if you'd just spent all of
your
calories yeah yeah you know what i mean
like that tank was empty yeah so you
needed to switch to a different tank
yeah i don't know but as i'll go into
this right honestly it felt like i had
something guiding me that whole time it
was a very strange experience
and anyway i won and it was great
of course i'm not gonna let go of this
metaphysical experience we're gonna we
are gonna come back to that probably
quickly but before we do for people who
are not going to
bank on having metaphysical experiences
or the feeling of being guided
what else have you learned about
regulating
yeah
whether it's the white noise or
especially for me of personal interest
when someone is actively trying to [ __ ]
with you and
disrupt
all of your systems
the best thing i've found it's super
simple is just breathing like
three deep breaths it's so
you know cookie cutter but it just works
just
close your eyes and
inhale in you can feel even if your
heart's pounding like my heart's
actually pounding a little bit now
because i'm retelling this story it's
funny you notice that you feel your body
you breathe in and you breathe it into
your belly and i i imagine
like my favorite color yeah which is
usually a mix of like turquoise and
purple something like that and i just
i'm
sucking that in
and pulling it down into my stomach and
then it's just like this
settling feeling and it's
harvey is just like bullshitting myself
you know like yeah
but it's an interrupt it's an interrupt
exactly and it and it just is enough to
like settle
your nervous system a second just ground
you back to here and then be like okay
now what's the problem you know another
thing that's helped as well is i just
like laughing at myself
like oh you're taking this one awfully
seriously you're silly like like i'm
like playing a silly little
in my head just to like make light of
the situation a bit but that requires a
lot of ability to sort of step out and
observe the situation because obviously
once you're in the red mist particularly
the red mist more than the white noise
by definition you are like animalistic
you are you don't have the ability to
step outside and observe a situation
well so
it's i think just practice really
practice by getting angry you know
practice reading i guess the way you
could do it is go like go read something
that you know makes you angry
like really like
reliably gets your blood pressure up and
then
try and like build in some kind of
trigger that makes you do the three
breaths thing so for 99.9 percent of the
sado masochistic users of twitter myself
included
just go on twitter yeah just go on
twitter every day yeah you'll be
reliably upset
for two minutes
oh
what a nasty neighborhood that's turned
into so sad you know as you were saying
this i'm imagining i'm imagining jason
listening to this and formulating in his
mind that's why i was working
for if he sees me taking deep breaths
he'd be like yeah timmy take those deep
breaths come on buddy you can do it oh
sorry i upset you oh yeah yeah i know
you're doing great yeah just close your
eyes don't even look at me no close your
eyes don't look at me don't worry no no
nothing you can't hear me yeah yeah
he'll just it's not like everybody's
waiting for you or anything
[Laughter]
all right before before i lose track
which i wouldn't but
what the hell happened in the morning
and you can contextualize this however
sure no i mean what happened was
you know like i played a bunch of these
tournaments not not of one's quite this
size but i'd still played a lot of
tournaments at this point
and
i was there before before it actually
started usually people turn up late but
for some reason i was there in my chair
before the first hand was dealt and i
remember they the the company poker
stars whose event it was
you know they dimmed the lights like
welcome to ebt san remo huge we've got
incredible feel blah blah
and then they they dimmed the lights and
they put on on the screens around the
room just like a promo exciting video
primary video you know
and i remember distinctly the music it
was chemical brothers hey boy hey girl
which i always loved i always loved that
song yeah good choice yeah and you know
i was like oh this is cool i'm excited
and while i was just like listening to
it just
like out of nowhere this like
it's like a bolt of lightning felt like
there was like this like
and this voice in my head said you are
going to win this tournament
and it sounded like my own voice but
what i can't remember is whether it was
i am going to win or you are going to
win but i'm pretty sure it was you are
going to win but it literally sounded
like my own voice and it was sounded
like your own voice yes it was like the
you know when you speak in your head
like the voice you hear like at least i
think most people have that right like
you know that tuesday voice everyone
hears
oh man i'm letting you learning a lot
out here um
just you know uh it sounded like how i
would sound in my own head to myself
and it said you are going to win this
tournament
and
i got this rush of goosebumps like
really like that oh you know it's even
happening a little bit like the hair's
up on my arms to the point where i was
like what and i remember looking around
the room like did did i just say that
out loud did anyone else hear this and
everyone else was just like in their
phones or whatever and i was like
well that was freaky
then the lights came back up and they're
like okay cool shuffle up and deal and i
was still like stunned and i was like
okay cool and then i sort of a little
bit forgot about it but then like
halfway through the day i got in a big
pot and i lost half my chips
and you know it's always a bad feeling
when that happens and i was like oh man
i'm nearly out the tournament i guess
that was [ __ ] you know so like
though i had like little multiple
moments
over the next few days where
i
you know i i it clearly was a real thing
because i've like checked in on it you
know and i was like oh this and i even
told a friend of mine on dinner do you
mean check checked in on it meaning you
remembered that it had happened that did
it happen well because obviously the
rational explanation to this is the like
it was just a false memory you know the
i have retroactively
remembered something that didn't really
happen as a way of like making
constructed exactly but you have
multiple points at which you referred to
it yes and i even have a friend my my
friend melanie who was there and i
bumped into her in the women's bathroom
on like day two and she's like oh you've
got a lot of chips it's going well i was
like yeah yeah things are going well
really weird i feel like i'm gonna win
this in fact i like i almost had a
premonition that i did and she's like
yeah you seem really confident and we
actually had this conversation and to
the point that she after i won it she
was like what the [ __ ] was that you you
like predicted this
i'm like i know i don't know
so
yeah
i don't know how to explain it
now
i think you said string or series
of experiences is that type of
experience in poker isolated to that
or i should and it doesn't have to be
constrained to poker right i'm just
wondering
what other stories you may have that
well
i so i had a few so what was interesting
was obviously
uh i apologize for
doing this herky jerky questioning style
but did you have any of those types of
experiences when you were younger
no no
i was not like a weird kid or you know
that had
sorry
let me start again
you weren't like the kid from the sixth
sense no i wasn't the sixth sense kid no
uh
no i did not is to answer that question
i had not really ever had i think
anything you know like i never saw a
ghost or anything like that i'm not
asking about ghosts i mean
don't lock me in with the ghost hunters
come on i don't but that
i want to just paint the picture of that
i was a very in fact like a deep skeptic
right well you still are do you
skeptical right right but like certainly
then like i'd never had anything weird
that i couldn't really explain in any
conventional way i'd certainly not had
any time loops or or anything like that
or weird voices in my head
but yeah to answer your question of like
is it a sort of common thing in poker no
not so much common thing in poker but
have you since had more of those types
of experiences
not of like explicit premonitions no i'm
not nothing even close to that i have
had
one really notable thing
that
is
yeah i i i i am happy to talk about it
if you change your mind we can cut it
later exactly
for want of a better word i had an
extreme energy healing
an almost accidental one
so it was a few years ago and
seemingly out of the blue i started
getting this very unpleasant sensation
in my ear
where
particularly it was like a sort of
low frequency buzzing humming quite
frequently like so some kind of tinnitus
but it was almost like a pressure
and
voices particularly men's voices became
distorted to the point that they were
unbearable to listen to
and it was really bumming me out because
it would come in like clusters i would
have it like for a few hours and it
would go away and come later on in the
day
and
it was stopping me from doing any social
events because any any loud scenario was
unbearable but particularly men speaking
i just couldn't handle it and this went
on and off for a few months and i went
and saw a doctor
multiple doctors and had hearing tests
and they said oh you're losing your
hearing and the low frequencies of your
of your hearing in that ear
we think you have meniere's disease
many airs is this degenerative thing
which usually people end up completely
deaf when they have it where basically
the the nerve cells in in the inner ears
start dying and they don't really know
why they think it's something to do with
like salts and ion channels and it's
incurable as far as i know and
and so i was told that's what i probably
have and they're like really sorry it's
you know it was just bad news to find
that out
and also because one of those
symptoms of it is you start having
balance problems as well you get like
these vertigo attacks and people like
vomiting and so on and so
you can imagine i was like really down
in the dumps finding this out
and then cut to
three months later or so uh go to
burning man
and
i have for the first time one of these
vertigo attacks on one of the one of the
days i mean i wasn't completely sober
but um it was not a good time as you can
imagine having a vertigo attack while
not being sober for the first time so i
was then really down in the dumps and
then on the last night of the burn
i was talking to some you know some
friends and started talking to this girl
who i kind of i don't know that well
but she's a friend of a friend
and i mentioned about my ear and she's
like oh well i do energy healing i'm an
energy healer
and i was like
i don't know what that is but sure do
whatever you want to do yeah have a go
she's like i can try
and
she sort of put her hand over my ear for
a few minutes and then she says i
remember saying something like there's
something there i need to get it
and she starts sucking over my ear with
her mouth like not touching it but just
like and it was really unpleasant
because like you can imagine that
sensation of someone like inhaling over
your ear and i was like oh please stop
she's like no i need to get this there's
something there
and she does it i don't know for a few
minutes and then eventually kind of
collapses in a heap on the floor crying
and freezing cold going oh my god that
was
that was bad i don't know what that was
that was really really bad
and
i
again i was not fully sober so this is a
slightly uh you know retelling but i
just remember being so shocked
because i i just didn't expect anything
to actually happen i didn't really feel
anything other than this like unpleasant
sensation of her sucking but i was so
shocked at the way she was now reacting
because she was shocked she
she did not seem to expect whatever had
just happened to her and she said
afterwards you know she came around
after a little while and she's like i
don't know what it was it was like
bad energy i don't know
it's gone i'm very pleased to say it's
fully gone and it's it's gone away and i
was like
well okay what does that mean for my
symptoms am i cured she's like yeah yeah
you'll probably have symptoms for a
couple more weeks and then you'll be
fine
and that's exactly what happened
and i haven't had any problems since
so
yeah i don't know
it kind of just blew my world open
because
aside of that premonition thing which i
kind of forgotten about
i have not
ever subscribed to
anything like that like i'm a physicist
in fact like you know i proud
i kind of built a career of being a like
materialist rationalist physicist
and i don't have any time for any of
that stuff it's all nonsense it's all
confirmation bias
you know
like no one's ever actually tested it
empirically or proven it you know show
me the study and i'll believe it but
here i am
having that experience with like
two what feel like pretty
incontrovertible data points that
something that i cannot explain
happened and unfortunately would be
incredibly beneficial to me like such a
blessing
so yeah
so these these experiences are
particularly
interesting to me right as
direct first-hand experiences
of course secondhand now that i'm
listening but are are particularly
interesting to me when i'm speaking with
someone who has demonstrated
a very well developed ability
to
use system two
thinking and
rationality and reasoning in mathematics
and
so on
in
not just the world but in competitive
arenas right so you have a
calibrated and also
tested ability to use those faculties
that you've developed
and
i'm glad you're mentioning these things
just because weird [ __ ] happens and the
idea that we have it all figured out is
ludicrous right even though humans at
any point in history whether you go back
to the middle ages the dark ages you
know i'm sure you know 6 000 years ago
or whatever it was with the egyptians
i'm sure they thought they had most
things figured out
and it's just
so clear when you begin to really poke
and prod and as you
gain more years and have more
experiences especially if you start
pushing into some strange corners
that there's a lot we simply don't
understand and
even if we were to
say not chalk those up to false memories
but let's just say we chalked up the
placebo effect right
nonetheless even if it were just placebo
effect
incredible that doesn't diminish the
absurd inexplicability
of it with the current
sort of mechanisms that we understand
right
and
that's super exciting to me it's super
exciting to me and it doesn't mean
that
you nor i would advocate that people
just accept everything at face value of
course not there's horse [ __ ] everywhere
i mean we're sitting in austin like the
world capital of spirituality there's so
much nonsense
and so many charlatans but i do pay
attention
to people like you
who have demonstrated in other areas
that they have the ability
to
think rationally
and have some grasp of you have a very
good grasp of science and so on right
that's kind of one of the first litmus
tests for me if someone's sharing
something with me i'm like all right
can this person show me can they fight
logically
out of a paper bag right like can they
have they demonstrated any ability to
use structured reasoning in other parts
are they able to cross examine their own
beliefs right exactly exactly and
uh are they
skeptical
in other areas or is it just like okay
they accept
anything as long as it's alternative
but they reject like western science for
any number of reasons that don't make
sense to me
if you've ever had antibiotics western
science
may have saved your life and there are
many other examples i certainly wouldn't
be here for more for western medicine
let's just say not science
i struggle with where to even take this
because there's so many directions that
could go that are pretty strange
and i don't want to co-opt physics so
please give me a slap here if this is
just an amateur
butchering the the good name of physics
but
when i've when i've talked to
i've had a number of cognitive
scientists on the podcast like donald
hoffman
i've had physicists on the podcast
although someone can consider michio
kaku more of a science communicator but
still has some fundamentals i've had
private conversations certainly with a
number of physicists
and i'm i i lack the the foundation of
mathematics necessary to fully
appreciate it but
when you even start to look at the
conversations that were being had
between einstein and bohr way back in
the day relative to
quantum mechanics
putting aside even
the
experimental design and evidence for
quantum entanglement
that have been done i think in the
canary islands and in other places
stuff is really strange right like just
even space-time itself as an objective
reality i mean there are pieces people
can find online by
qualified scientists
on the death of space-time right and
thinking about
that as uh almost a ui that we have
evolved to utilize but not as the one
and only user interface to
whatever we might be contending with and
like donald hoffman even thinks that
well and not just donald hoffman i mean
he thinks that
consciousness essentially gives rise to
space yeah and
while a lot of
theoretical physicists
poopoo his ideas and i think by and
large they are correct too
even
they would agree that it seems like
space itself is an emergent property
it's not a fundamental thing you know
we're not objects rattling around in a
big empty box
it is
a
thing that emerges from
basically interactions of mathematical
functions
whether it's on a substrate or whether
it i don't know if it even needs a
substrate i'm i'm too rusty on that
stuff but it's super weird if you dig
into the fundamental structure of this
like you know wiccan
witchcraft shop with like tarot cards in
the display case not to knock that right
but like we're talking about
some of the most esteemed scientists in
a hard science
with peer-reviewed publications and so
on if you just look at that stuff
closely enough
shit's really weird yeah there's a paper
i was recently reading that's like
digging into
the
that it seems like space time is
what space itself is essentially coming
out of observers interacting with each
other consciousness is interacting with
each other but it's really
from what i can tell really granular
legit physics i mean it's a math paper
basically um it's beyond my pay grade so
i want to send it to like sean carroll i
don't know if you've ever had him on
sean carroll i haven't had on but my
brother introduced me to his podcast
mindscape isn't it
excellent podcast so good so if sean
carroll is out there listening or if
anyone knows him let him know i'm a i
mean
he may not want to hear this i don't
know what his opinion will be
but big fan of his podcast he is a damn
fine thinker and a damn fine
communicator he really is yeah and he
had an excellent
episode
on
i think it was sort of an archaeological
exploration of
stonehenge and other
artifacts as
external mnemonic devices
super cool
so liv olivia
question for you
how do you
as someone who is a
trained
rationalist materialist although you may
not identify as
solely those things i don't want to
imply that how do you integrate some of
these experiences
into your
life your framework your world view what
do you do with that it's tricky i think
with all these things it's like
walking this fine line between
gullibility open-mindedness whatever you
want to call it and skepticism and
cynicism
and
i think where my poker training comes in
handy is that poker trains you to think
improbabilities you're never certain
about anything like you could have aces
or you could be bluffing me with six
four suited that missed the card it
needed so you become very comfortable in
terms of like living like holding
concurrent belief states in your mind
with different weighted probabilities of
those things being true
so
with these like you know these two weird
unexplainable experiences that i had you
know whether it was the ear thing was
just pure placebo which would still be
crazy because it would mean that like
basically i have the ability to
heal my mind by thinking i was going
through some kind of like
thing being sucked out my ear fine
potentially feel your inner ear yeah
like i was literally told i had a
degenerative thing i was gonna go deaf
and like no one's been cured of it and
this has miraculously gone away so
whatever the hell happened the point is
i didn't go and change my life i didn't
suddenly go and be like that's it i'm
gonna go and practice energy healing and
become a witch and so on like i still am
an adherent to the scientific method
it's just that i've now broadened my you
know as you mentioned like you know it's
almost like people believe in the
scientism as opposed to being scientists
a true scientist is that you are
maximally curious and you truly you do
your best to devise experiments
in order to get reliable robust results
that can you can use to predict the
world and you try and minimize all the
biases and things that could mess up
your experiment and give you a faulty
result and so
there's no reason why i can't
incorporate
these two data points in terms of i mean
i haven't gone out and done any science
i really should i guess go and do some
tests and see if i can try and recreate
those
that experience but it's very difficult
because it was a set and setting were
very important and what happened there i
would assume anyway i don't know that
but well when they make the netflix
series about it and they recreate the
entire environment and then you can sit
down and try to recreate yeah so what i
guess i've done is i have up weighted
you know whereas before i would have
given the probability that like energy
healing is a real thing i would have
given it like a
you know well probably if you'd asked my
old like skeptical self i would have
literally said it's zero but you know i
wasn't so such a bad basing that i would
give it actual zero maybe like one in a
million
daisy
oh that's good we can't we don't have
time to unpack that
like you know i've been giving it a one
in a million
and now i have updated it you know with
this evidence to
how many orders of magnitude
do i want to go i mean i will give it i
at least give it a one in 100. yeah you
know
but do i give it more than
i still give it i think it's more likely
that there is a
an explanation through what we know
conventionally
that is still more probable than that it
is something completely like some
completely novel thing that is untapped
but that said you know i've actually had
a few other little ones i won't go into
but like other little data points of
just like weird energy things that have
happened in certain scenarios where i've
like it's helped me and so on but
it's still important to
keep the like skeptical hat on yeah
and you know extraordinary beliefs
require extraordinary evidence
and
in order for me to like give up
everything that i know about current our
current understanding of the world i
would need significantly more data
points and i think that it's just not
the practical way to go forward
yeah i would also add to that that
if folks want to be proper skeptics
you owe it to yourself and to the people
you interact with to be an informed
skeptic so if you are going to
invoke the name of science
and
not invoke it like the name of odin in
some like
you know god works in mysterious ways
kind of way
you need to actually my opinion have the
ability to read a study and understand a
study and study design it's not good
enough to get
the journalistic interpretation from the
wall street journal or fill in the blank
online publication that's not good
enough it's also not good enough for you
to just get the gist of a few senses in
an abstract confidence intervals right
so confidence intervals understanding
powering on because you'll also find
folks who and i always i've been saying
sciencism but i guess it's scientism the
sort of capital s in either case it has
a capital s and it's not good so if if
you succumb to that one of the telltale
characteristics that i've come across is
they'll ask if something was a
controlled study or a placebo-controlled
randomized study randomized control you
know rct and then say well how many
how many subjects were there or what was
the n if they get you know fancy and
i might say 20 25 and they're like oh
yeah
small study nonsense and i'm like it's
not that
simplistic
there are a lot there are quite a few
variables you have to take into account
so recommendations for folks
who are interested number one
studying the studies by
peter tiamdi excellent series of blog
posts
that
take you into the fundamentals of
understanding
how to dissect and understand a study
which includes meta-analyses and gets
into the
risks of taking meta-analyses as gospel
also because garbage in garbage out and
there's there's a lot to it
another recommendation actually a
podcast that i did
six years ago i realized when i pulled
this up
this is podcast number 194 the magic and
power of placebo this is with eric vance
who wrote a book
called suggestible you subtitled the
curious science of your brain's ability
to deceive transform and heal
and he's written very widely on placebo
is an excellent book
many of his feature pieces are
exceptional
there's a great piece in wired magazine
probably 10 years ago on the
the evolution of the placebo effect and
how it has changed depending on the
culture
and other influences so in certain
places say a placebo pill in a blue
capsule or a red capsule perform better
than other colors it's really don't have
a blue red one at this stage
that's true yeah we can pick other
colors but
the the context that surrounds that is
is really really interesting and then
the last thing i would recommend people
check out is
cognitive biases and looking at both
frameworks intended to avoid them and
just getting a better understanding so
you can go to wikipedia and just look up
cognitive biases and get a pretty basic
list
you can look at something like port
charlie's almanac with charlie munger
although it's a bit dense and
it's a little user unfriendly
in a lot of respects but what were you
gonna say i would recommend some of
julia gailiff's work
yeah absolutely the scout mindset and
uh motivated reasoning what was the
first one
the scout mindset scout yeah i mean she
did a ted talk on it but she's just
written a book on it as well and i think
she actually goes in if i remember
rightly she's her last name is g-a-l-e-f
yes yeah you know when i first learned
about rationality like i you know read
everything unless wrong
if people know that which is incredible
resource for it and it you know really
breaks down
you know how you get this you know your
brain which is like the map to match the
actual territory which is the universe
as accurately as possible
but
where i think it's maybe lacking a
little bit now because i've had some of
these weirder experiences where i wasn't
you know in the classical sense rational
like i you know clearly went off the
beaten path into some like weird land
but it was actually very beneficial to
me even if it was like some completely
useful fiction it was still useful yeah
yeah you know and this idea of like
useful fictions i think needs to be
explored further yeah i'd also add that
much like poker science i don't think a
lot of folks realize is largely
a game of probabilities yeah you don't
prove something a hundred percent most
of the time it's like well literally
never actually exactly i mean you can
have overwhelmingly compelling data even
with say an observational study say with
the sort of quintessential example would
be cigarette smoking causing
lung cancer right
but most of the times like this suggests
with this degree of certainty that this
is the case but when you start to look
at the replication crisis which is not
just in social sciences it's all over
the place
and
especially if you start to actually
roll up your sleeves and get involved in
science whether that's as a subject i've
been a subject in studies at all sorts
of places i started doing it as an
undergrad i was a subject in one of uh
daniel kahneman's studies
and
it was not very intellectually engaging
it was like space bar every time like a
green
square popped up or something but i
needed the seven dollars an hour or
whatever it was
and i've been a subject at stanford with
heat exhaustion experiments that was
also not terribly fun
marching to exhaustion with like an
esophageal probe and an anal probe kind
of meeting in the middle in fatigues
with weights on a treadmill and a sauna
to like complete
mental collapse geez
yeah so why do i do these things because
i'm interested in seeing the process
and
even some of the best science you could
point to in the most prestigious
journals when you actually get in there
it's a lot messier than people think
right but people want to have confidence
in something then the religion has
become so out of fashion that they look
to the high priests of science and
they're like at least i have the
confidence in this being true
so i actually wanted one of my next
videos i want to make on this which is
about basically these signaling prestige
bad incentives that get society stuck in
these kind of
these traps essentially
so we're stuck in one of those with
the current status quo of the way
science is done and this is not at all
to knock any scientists you know they're
doing their absolute best but this the
way the system has been designed we give
all the rewards to the people who first
create the like you know
make the new fancy discovery and don't
give any credit to the people who then
actually replicate it and verify it yeah
totally so there's this incredible
incentive to be always looking for some
new novel thing yeah
in order to get that you know your thing
published in nature and get those
research dollars for the next time but
it doesn't actually really advance human
knowledge yeah because
so many of these things don't replicate
so sort of like we're sort of stuck in
the spiral of just like everyone's
trying to do whatever they can to get in
the journal there's a name for it so
there's this really incredible short
online book called inadequate equilibria
okay by the guy who wrote most of the
stuff on less wrong eliezer yotkowski
and i recommend in adequate equilibrium
yes
oh man i know it sounds it's so good it
has one of the best things it has a
discussion a fictitious discussion with
an alien from a perfect society a basic
person who thinks everything's wrong in
our society is because of like there's
bad people being greedy and then with a
cynical smart economist and they have
this three-way discussion talking about
like reason why the u.s healthcare
system is so expensive and it sort of
goes into this meandering thing about it
that's a cool premise it's so good like
like you must include this in the show
notes how long would you say it is um i
mean ideally they read
they could just read chapter three
honestly it's like a 40 45 minute read
oh it's yes sure yeah it's like a book
chapter and you can kind of read a
standalone we'll put this we'll put it
in the show notes but basically it's
it's talking about these traps that we
can get into where it gets people now
speaking game theory
it it gets society stuck in like shitty
nash equilibria so a nash equilibrium is
when you know two people or multiple
people are playing in a strategy where
it would be bad for anyone to deviate
from that strategy it's like everyone's
stuck doing that but not all nash
equilibria are actually created equal
there are some where if everyone was
doing
you know x instead of y
everyone would be happier they'd also be
like you know now stuck in a new thing
like a good example of this would be
well so i just made a video on uh called
the beauty wars
about this like fictitious thing called
molok which i call like the demon of
negative sum games basically it's like
the god of negative some games it's a
force of bad
usually economic incentives that make
people sort of sacrifice things that
they want in order to optimize for a
short-term goal and the example i talk
about is these beauty filters on
instagram i don't know if you've spent
anything they are
horrifying i mean in how dramatic they
are i'd never seen these things before
until my girlfriend showed them to me
and i was
dumbfounded they're so well they're
horrifying not only in how impressively
good they are at doing stuff but also
how
now the really insidious ones are the
subtle ones
because there are some
where you would never you'd go online
and you would not be able to tell if you
don't know the person or even if you
know the person you wouldn't necessarily
be able to tell you just think it's a
good picture of them they're so subtle
but they're so effective it seems like
there is clearly just some kind of
optimal face structure that you know our
eyes find pleasing and it just tweaks
people makes the eyes a little bit wider
apart or a little bit bigger or the lips
you know changes the proportions just
right that it sets the dopamine spike
off in your brain
and it's gonna make online dating really
hard oh man and well so as a girl and
it's not that i'm on the field i'm not
on the playing field but but right if i
were that sounds like a headache well
and but also for people who use them
like so i'm a girl on instagram you know
i for a while certainly like made a lot
of my career off the way i looked
like there's such an incentive pressure
you know if i want to keep playing the
game of trying to grow my instagram like
a sexy picture yes the arms race exactly
and that's what moloka's monica's this
like the god of arms races and it's like
these these bad incentives like the
cheap thing for me to do is just to use
one of these ai filters on on all my
pictures and i know i'm going to look
good and i'm going to get a ton of likes
and it'll grow my thing but
it will make me miserable in the process
and
if you polled most particularly women on
on instagram they are not having a good
time with these things either on
themselves because if you then like
compare your face side to side
you're just like man you just it just
makes you feel ugly and so we're in this
weird situation where no one wants to do
stuff that makes them hate their face
but they're doing it anyway and that's
what this it's like a lower nash
equilibrium you know we could all be in
a higher nash equilibrium where we're
not doing it but instead we're all stuck
down there because of these bad game
theoretical incentives so this is my
current obsession this thing called
molok and i think about it all the time
m-o-l-o-c-h for people wondering and
we'll link to that in the show notes so
just underscore this for folks because i
do suggest that everybody check out your
youtube channel what's the best way for
them to find
your channel probably the best thing is
if they search for my name and then the
beauty wars
that'll link to the video i just talked
about all right and then you can find my
channel from and uh just for the
spelling everybody it's liv liv last
name
b-o-e-r-e-e
which means i learned just beforehand
drunk farmer
so they say
they say and i did grow up on a farm
and i did drink a lot it's so good
so good yeah ferris you know the best i
can tell you're a big wheel it
could be that it also refers to
ferrous like ferrous oxide f-e-r-o-u-s
because apparently
some of
my
progenitors were silversmiths i don't
know how it all fits together seems like
a very dubious story i'm not sure but i
want i want some story to go along with
the last time
but i don't have drunken farmer that's
an amazing one
uh liv we should do a round two sometime
when we're practically neighbors we have
so much we could talk about we've got a
million other things even in the notes
in front of me that we could cover and
should cover
i'm thinking about this training are you
gonna do it ah
we'll see requires more mezcal to make
that decision
i think we could we could condense it
down we don't have to do the full eight
weeks i think
commit to even three weeks honestly i
think you would
jkl will still be better than you at
that stage i have to say that no he
would be
all right three weeks three weeks i'm
going to i'm going to sleep on that i do
my best thinking when i'm asleep so
let me sleep on that is there anything
else that you would like to say any
closing comments places you'd like to
point people anything at all you like to
say before we before we wind this down
no i mean i guess
do check out my youtube now i've moved
to austin and i'm like building a studio
and everything i'm going to be ramping
up production again so i would love
people to go and just
sub to my channel so that they catch my
stuff because of you know playing the
rat race
the attention wars that's the name of
the next video is the attention wars
which is about that like why twitter and
everything is making us so angry and
hate each other oh
yeah
that's a big one talk about a nasty game
yeah and molok molok's in that molecule
molex all over that
so liv
we're going to link to everything in the
show notes uh people can find you at
liveburrie.com also which i i would
imagine has links to many things
and we'll put links to everything we've
discussed all the resources in adequate
equilibria
and uh
all other good things
in the show notes at team dot blog slash
podcast
and
so nice to see you thanks for taking the
time this is awesome super fun super fun
and for everybody listening as per usual
thanks for tuning in
and until next time just be a little
kinder to yourselves
and to others than you think is
necessary and take care
you